-Well, guys,
I've always said that
the best advice comes from kids.
So with that in mind,
it's time for "Kid Advice."
Here we go.
-♪ "Kid Advice" ♪
♪ Advice ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But, first, I'm gonna need
someone to help me.
His children's book,
"The One and Only Sparkella
Makes a Plan,"
is out May 31st.
Please welcome Channing Tatum,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yeah! That's my man. Hey!
Good to see you, buddy.
Channing.
-Yes, sir.
-Channing, we asked our
viewers at home to send in
some advice that their kids had.
We got so many
amazing responses,
and I thought that
maybe we could read
some of our favorites right now.
Does that sound okay to you?
-Please. Absolutely.
-Alright, here we go.
I will start.
[ Clears throat ]
[ Lullaby playing ]
That's true.
Channing, your turn.
-That's actually good advice.
3 years old.
How about this one?
-Wow.
That's a long one.
Alright, this one's good.
That's fantastic.
-I'm down with Sophie.
-That's actually --
This is great advice.
How about this one?
Our final one -- You want to
bring us home, Channing?
Give us the
final piece of advice.
"Inhale. Outhale."
Thank you to all our kids.
Thank you to Channing Tatum!
My man!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
His new children's book,
"The One and Only Sparkella
Makes a Plan,"
is available May 31st.
Thank you for doing that,
Channing.
I appreciate it, buddy.
-Thank you, guys.